now that we know a little bit about
Newton's first law let's give ourselves
a little quiz and what I want you to do
is figure out which of these statements
are actually true and our first
statement is if the net force on a body
is zero its velocity will not change
interesting statement number two an
unbalanced force on a body will always
impact the object's speed also an
interesting statement statement number
three the reason why initially moving
objects tend to come to rest in our
everyday life is because they are being
acted on by unbalanced forces and
statement for an unbalanced force on an
object will always change the object's
direction so I'll let you think about
that so let's think about these
statement by statement so our first
statement right over here if the net
force on a body zero its velocity will
not change this is absolutely true this
is actually even another way of thinking
about what another way of rephrasing
Newton's first law if I have if I have
some type of object that's just
traveling through space with some
velocity so it has some speed going in
some direction and maybe it's deep space
and we can just for purity assume it
there's no gravitational interactions
there always be some miniscule one but
we'll assume no gravitational
interactions absolutely no particles
that it's bumping into absolute vacuum
of space this thing will travel on
forever its velocity will not change
neither at speed nor its direction will
change so this one is absolutely true
statement number two an unbalanced force
on a body will always impact the
object's speed and the key word right
over here is speed if I had written
impact the object's velocity then this
would be a true statement an unbalanced
force on a on a body will always impact
the object's velocity that would be true
but we wrote speed here speed is the
magnitude of velocity does not take into
account the direction
and to see why the second statement is
false you can think about a couple of
things and we'll do more videos on the
intuition of centripetal acceleration
and centripetal forces inward forces if
this does not make complete intuitive
sense to you just at this moment but
imagine we're looking at an ice skating
rink from above and you have an ice
skater this is the ice skaters head and
they're traveling in that direction now
imagine right at that moment right at
that moment they grab a rope that is
nailed to a stake in the ice skating
rink right over there reviewing all of
this from above and this right over here
is the rope now what is going to happen
well the skater the skater is going to
travel their direction is actually going
to change and they can hold on to the
rope and as long as they hold onto the
rope they'll keep going in circles and
when they let go of the rope they'll
start going they'll start going in
whatever direction they were traveling
in when they let go they'll keep going
in on in that direction and if we assume
it very very very small frictions from
the ice skating rink they'll actually
have the same speed so the force the
inward force the tension from the rope
pulling on the skater in this situation
would have only changed the skaters
direction so an unbalanced force doesn't
necessarily have to impact the object
speed it often does but in that
situation it would have only impacted
the skaters direction another situation
like this and once again this involves
centripetal acceleration inward inward
forces inward acceleration is a
satellite in orbit or any type of thing
in orbit so if that is if that is some
type of planet and this is one of the
planets moons right over here the reason
why it stays in orbit is because the
pull of gravity keeps making the object
change its direction but not its speed
its speed is the exact right speed so as
it travels so this was its speed right
here if the planet wasn't there would
just keep going on in that direction
forever and forever but the planet right
over here there's an inward force of
gravity and we'll talk more about the
force of gravity in the future but this
inward force of gravity is going to
accelerate this object inwards while it
travels and so after some period of time
this object's velocity vector if you add
the previous velocity
with how much it's changed with how much
it's changed it's new velocity vector
now this is after it's traveled a little
bit it's new velocity vector might look
something like might look something like
this and it's traveling at the exact
right speed so that the inward force or
so that the force of gravity is always
at a right angle to its actual to its to
its actual trajectory it's the exact
right speed so it doesn't go off into
deep space and so it doesn't plummet
into the earth and we'll cover that into
much more detail but the simple answer
is unbalanced force on a body will
always impact its velocity it could be
its speed its direction or both but it
doesn't have to be both it could be just
the speed or just the direction so this
is an in correct statement now the third
statement the reason why initially
moving objects tend to come to rest in
our everyday life is because they are
being acted on by unbalanced forces this
is absolutely true and this is the
example we gave the reason why if I take
an object if I take my book and I try to
slide it across the desk the reason why
it eventually comes to stop is because
we have the unbalanced force of friction
but the grinding of the surface of the
book with the grinding of the table if I
if I'm inside of a pool and even if
there's absolutely no current in the
pool and if I were to if I were to try
to push some type of object inside the
water it eventually comes to a stop
because of all of the resistance all of
the resistance of the water itself it's
providing an unbalanced force in a
direction opposite its motion that is
what's slowing it down so in our
everyday life the reason why we don't
see these things go on and on forever is
that we have these frictions these air
resistance the the the or or or the
friction with actual surfaces and then
the last statement an unbalanced force
on an object will always change the
object's direction well this one
actually is maybe the most intuitive we
always have the situation if I have a
let's say I have a block right over here
and it's traveling with some velocity in
that direction five meters per second if
I apply an unbalanced force in that same
direction in that same direction so
that's my force right over there if I
if I apply it in that same direction I'm
just going to accelerate it in that same
direction so I won't necessarily change
it even if I were to act against it I
might decelerate it but I won't
necessarily change its direction I could
change its direction by doing something
like this but I don't necessarily I'm
not always necessarily changing the
object's direction so this is this is
not true an unbalanced force on an
object will not always change the
object's direction it can like these
circumstances but not always so always
is what makes this very very very wrong